madame monsieur bonsoir Yasser Arafat
demain à Strasbourg la polémique
s'amplifie pour la première fois les
représentants de l'OLP de la communauté
juive française se parlent dans ce
journal la longue marche des réfugiés
kurdes qui fuit l'Irak il n'aurait pas
été victime d'armes chimique affirment
les autorités turques une centaine de
viols en 15 ans dans la région d'ex
c'est le palmarès d'un père de famille
modèle un kfier dans l'hémicycle
européen l'événement aura lieu demain à
Strasbourg Yasser Arafat le chef de
l'OLP s'y rendra à l'invitation du
groupe socialiste de l'Assemblée
européenne déjà laatenstion monte on
s'attend à Strasbourg à des
manifestations contradictoires et le
Conseil représenta des associations
juives de France donne le ton avec cette
page plein cadre publié dans le monde de
ce soir théoclin bonsoir vous êtes le
président du CRIF Ibrahim sous vous
êtesvous on le sait le représentant de
l'OLP en France on va pour une fois vous
entendre ensemble côte à côte développer
vos arguments sinon amorcer un dialogue
mais d'abord situons dans son contexte
cette première visite en France de
Yasser F avec Gill
Rabine le kfier Palestinien dans
l'enceinte de l'ONU cette image le 22
novembre 74 avait provoqué une polémique
de dimension mondiale de cette tribune
réservée aux chefs et aux représentants
des États le monde entier avait pu
suivre le discours de Yasser Arafat chef
officiel d'une organisation qui prenait
officiellement le terrorisme comme moyen
privilégié dans sa lutte contre Israël
Arafat était reparti de l'ONU avec la
reconnaissance officielle du droit à à
l'indépendance des Palestiniens depuis
pour donner plus de crédibilité
politique à l'OLP Yasser Arafat a saisi
toutes les occasions qui se présenté à
lui reçu en 82 par le Parlement italien
puis la même année en audience privée
par le pape Jean-Paul II rencontrant à
Beyrouth en 81 Claude chesson alors
ministre français des Affaires
étrangères puis son successeur Roland
Duma à Tunis en 85 consacré enfin par
ses frères arabes en juin dernier à
Alger comme représentant des
Palestiniens après 10 mois de guerre des
pierres dans les territoires occupés par
Israël et surtout après le coup de
théâtre qu'à constitué début août
l'abandon par le roi Hussein de Jordanie
de toute souveraineté sur ces mêmes
territoires occupés le chef de l'OLP
saisira-t-il l'occasion de cette
première visite à Strasbourg en France
pour faire un geste décisive la marche
de manœuvre d'Arafat est étroite parce
qu'il est marqué de très près par
l'ailure de l'OLP à quelques semaines du
Conseil palestinien et parce qu'il ne
veut pas gêner les modérés israéliens
dans le campagne
électorale thoclin bonsoir vous êtes
donc le président du CRIF dans le grand
TCAR que vous publiez dans le monde de
ce soir vous le dites carrément pour
vous Yasser Arafat est un terroriste et
les Français s'en souviennent cela
voudrait donc dire que cette invitation
à l'assemblée européenne est une faute
ou
pire je crois que c'est effectivement
une faute en tout cas une faute dans le
temps nous n'avons pas dit que Monsieur
Arafat était personnellement un
terroriste nous avons simplement dit
qu'il était à la tête d'une organisation
qui prenait le terrorisme et qui
d'ailleurs avait réussi brillamment à
introduire de nouvelles forme de
terrorisme celle qui empoisonne la vie
des européens notamment et de bien
d'autres gens à travers le monde et nous
pensons nous pensons qu'il ne faut
peut-être pas l'oublier dans certaines
circonstances une erreur dans le temps
donc à votre avis c'est une erreur de
calendrier ou une erreur de principe
c'est une erreur à la fois de calendrier
et de principe pour l'instant car nous
attendons que l'OLP éventuellement
déclare qu'elle abandonne la violence
pour choisir la voie de la solution
politique et là jusqu'à présent rien n'a
été fait dans ce sens-là et les quelques
paroles qui ont pu être dites ou les
quelques extraits de déclaration de Abou
Sharif ou de abouyad semble avoir été
immédiatement contredite alors justement
Ibrahim sous votre réplique le le RAM
d'Olivier ou le pistolet j'accuse
théoclin de pratiquer
l'amalgame et la formation pour masquer
les crimes de l'armée d'occupation
israélienne dans les territoires
occupés il éitoclin dit que les
Palestiniens doivent renoncer à la
violence que fait Israël dans les
territoires occupés c'est-il théoclin
aujourd'hui que nous sommes au
280e mort palestinien sait-il quel est
Laâge l'âge moyen de ces morts
palestiniens je vais vous le dire
monsieur clin 15 ans c'est-il l'âge
moyen de tous ceux qu'on tire au milieu
de la nuit de leur maison
qu'on détruit leur maison c'est-il l'âge
moyen de ceux qui sont dans les camps
des concentrations au sud d'Israël des
milliers et des milliers qui cropissent
là-bas 15 ans Monsieur clin et vous Z me
dire renoncer à la violence renonceer à
quoi jeter des pierres dit aux
Israéliens que vous défendez de renoncer
à tirer sur nos enfants monsieur cl oui
je je regrette ces paroles d'Ibrahim
sous elle soulignent le fait
qu'effectivement l'OLP n'est pas prête
au di
car c'est un peu facile d'employer ces
arguments le terrorisme qui attaque des
gens qui par hasard passent dans une rue
passent devant une synagogue déjeunent
dans un restaurant font leurs achats
dans une galerie de de commerciale ù se
trouve sur le city of Poros ne peut pas
être comparé à ceux que vous traitez par
ailleurs de vaillants combattants de
l'iltifada moi je regrette tous les
morts Monsieur Ibrahim sous mais je
voudrais aussi vous rappeler que les
Arabes et parfois des Palestiniens
eux-mêmes ont tué beaucoup plus de vos
frères que les Israéliens ne le feront
jamais Septembre noir ce sont pas les
Israéliens moi j'ai vu en Septembre noir
j'étais en Israël et j'ai vu des
Palestiniens se réfugier en Israël et
dernièrement Sabra et Chatila ont été
détruit par des israéliens ou ont été
détruits par des Palestiniens alors je
vous en prie c'est vous qui avez
introduit cette violence dans la région
et je voudrais vous citer un texte
Monsieur Ibrahim sous un texte dont vous
connaissez peut-être l'auteur et si
c'est ce texte que vous me prononciez
aujourd'hui à ce moment-là le dialogue
serait
possible c'est un arabe qui souhaite la
bienvenue aux
exilés à ses frères je cite à ses frères
originaires du pays dont leurs frères
arabes devraient profiter matériellement
aussi bien que
spirituellement et puis une autre
citation d'un des premiers nationalistes
arabes pas un seul arabe véritable ne
peut nourrir de soupçons à l'égard du
nationalisme juif ou en être effrayé
nous luttons pour la liberté arabe et
nous nous en montrerions indigne vous
entendez Monsieur Ibrahim sous indigne
si nous ne disions pas aux Juifs comme
je le fais soyez les bienvenus de retour
à la maison la première citation est du
roi Hussein pas le roi housussein de
Jordanie le roi du Hedjaz et la deuxème
est de l'émir fessal à une époque où les
nationalistes arabes comptaient sur les
nationalistes juifs pour pouvoir obtenir
ce qu'ils n'ont pas obtenu parce que
entre les Anglais et les Français il y
avait quelques querelles précisément
monsieur monsieur sous monsieur clin
demain Yasser Arafat à Strasbourg une
occasion d'éclaircir les choses
d'avancer peut-être dans ce que l'on
souhaite toujours une amorce de dialogue
possible monsieur sous je ne contesterai
pas à théoclin cette leçon d'histoire
falsifié tout ce que je peux lui dire
c'est qu'il a cherché il a cherché à me
joindre à plusieurs reprises par des
amis communs j'ai toujours dit oui pour
discuter il n'a jamais donner suite
malheureusement le le problème est son
langage est ce que vous dites monsieur
clin est très confus moi ce que je vous
dit aujourd'hui est-ce que vous êtes
prêt à garantir que les Israéliens
renoncent à tirer sur le peuple
palestinien de massacrer ses enfants
pour parvenir à la paix est-ce qu'il y a
un seul représentant israélien qui
voudrait venir s'asseoir à une table de
négociation avec un responsable
palestinien je vous je vous mets à défi
nous nous nous sommes prêts Yas Arafat
vient demain avec un message de paix il
va dire la chose suivante il va dire je
suis porteur d'un message de paix je
veux vivre en coexistence sur cette même
terre de Palestine déchirée avec le
peuple israélien est-ce qu'il y a un
seul israélien courageux et suffisamment
visionnaire pour venir faire la paix
avec moi monsieur dernier mot un dernier
mot mais c'est évident que si les
enfants arabes allaient dans l'école les
Israéliens ne tireraient pas sur eux
s'ils ne lançaient pas des pierres s'il
ne lançaient pas des cocktails molotop
ils ne seraient pas atteint il c'est
scandaleux monsieur ce n'est pas
scandaleux scandaleux monsur mon est
scandaleux c'est que d'unout à l'ut vous
imaginez les soldats
français imaginez la police frçise
quelqu
si c'est comme ça que vous envisagez le
dialogue il sera
effectivement dans non c'est vous qui
dites n'importeoi vous dit les
enfants C je crains que ce dialogue ne
tourne à double monono je vous remercie
tous deux en tout cas d'être d'être là
côte à côte d'une certaine manière je
vous rappelle donc que Yasser Arafat est
attendu demain à Strasbourg même s'il
visite une instance européenne et ne se
rend pas à proprement parler en France
ça venue créer un malaise certain jusque
chez les socialistes français associés
au gestes du groupe parlementaire de
Strasbourg députés et sénateurs
socialistes sont précisément réunis
depuis ce matin à Vienne dans l'iser
pour discuter entre eux de la situation
politique et des projets du gouvernement
Pascal Guimier est sur
place il traînent un peu des pieds à
l'idée de parler d'un certain Yasser
Arafat ou bien tout simplement histoire
de ne pas avoir l'air de godillot
marchant au pas parlementaire socialiste
au vert venu apporter la dernière touche
à la session budgétaire aujourd'hui à
Vienne on accueillli les premiers fruits
du dialogue parti
gouvernement plat de résistance c'est le
cas de le dire l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune la base réclamait l'aile
comme la cuisse en clair un impôt à la
fois plus large et plus fort argument
avancés taxer davantage les riches pour
donner plus aux pauvres impôt sur la
fortune contre revenu minimum
d'insertion l'heure est maintenant au
compromis l'outil de travail sera bien
exonéré comme le voulait le gouvernement
en contrepartie les taux d'imposition
seront relevés comme le réclamaient les
députés la discussion interne tire à sa
fin place au débat politique ce qui nous
rappelaient parfois avec des accents
angoissants
euh la situation des nouveaux pauvres
dans les années 84 et
85 vont pouvoir désormais
mettre en accord leurs actes et leurs
paroles bref les socialistes camperont
désormais sur leur position outil de
travail exonéré plutôt de quoi rassurer
à droite tau relevé de quoi amindouer
unant soit peu les communistes mais pas
question de renier ses idées au nom
d'allian qui n'existe pas les
passerelles sont jetées aux autres de
franchir le pas première sanction des
instances du RPR à l'encontre de deux
secrétaires de circonscription qui
n'avaient pas envie de condamner
l'alliance électorale avec le Front
national à vitrol et à Berk ils ont été
suspendus la comparaison des extrêmes en
politiqu échauffent les esprits George
marchetis hier s'était insurgé contre le
parallèle établi par Valéri giscardestin
entre le Parti communiste et le Front
National et bien c'est autour du Front
national aujourd'hui d'accuser le
secrétaire général du PC d'être je cite
le représentant en France de la plus
sanglante imposture de l'histoire fin de
citation comment t'effacer 10 mois de
tiédeur dans les relations
franco-tunisiennes et bien la République
dépoiss s fastes pour le successeur de
monsieur bourgiba le Président Benali
est arrivé cet après-midi à Paris pour
une visite officielle de 3 jours au
programme le recerement des liens
économiques militaires et culturels
entre les deux
pays cinq petits marocains en classe
comme tout le monde depuis ce matin à
Casseneuil en lotégaron le maire qui
vous vous en souvenez s'opposait à leur
intégration a obéi à l'injonction du
ministre de l'éducation nationale et du
préfet un passe en revanche au lycée
grandmond de tour le personnel
enseignant est toujours en grève pour
manque de moyens un nototage à l'air
libre on attend de façon imminente à
Beyrouth la réapparition de Rudolphe
cordes cet Allemand de l'Ouest enlevé en
janvier 87 et on s'interroge sur les
conditions de sa libération de bonne
Philippe
Rochot voici laal dans laquelle cordè
annonce sa libération et demande à
l'Allemagne de faire un geste en faveur
du terroriste Mohamed amadey le
communiqué des ravisseurs de l'otage
parle de changement de politique
internationale allusion à la paix entre
l'Irak et l'Iran et montre qu'ils ont
cédé aux pressions de Damas et théran
mais sans obtenir la libération de
Mohamed amadey actuellement jugé à
Francfort car c'est pour lui et pour son
frère Abbas arrêté pour trafique
d'explosif que deux ingénieurs allemands
ont été enlevés à Beyrout en janvier 87
or Mohamed Amade aurait exécuté ce
passager américain Robert Steem lors du
détournement du vol TW sur beyouth en
juin 85 les Allemands avaiit pu obtenir
la libération d'Alfred schmidth en
septembre 87 en acceptant de ne pas
extrader amadeille vers les États-Unis
mais le pilote et les passagers de la TW
accablent aujourd'hui Mohamed amadeille
qui ne serait autre que l'homme à la
cagoule qui dirigeait le commando pas
question donc de le relâcher pour le
moment mais pas question de l'extrader
vers les États-Unis l'Allemagne fédérale
se serait engagé auprès de
l'Iran comment libérer cordes alors que
tous les témoignages accusent Mohamed
amadey d'avoir détourné le Boeing de la
TW sur beyouth et d'avoir abattu le
passager américain en fait Amade serait
condamné fermement par la justice
allemande mais pourrait bénéficier plus
tard d'une réduction de peine il y a
donc eu tractation mais les Allemands
ont sans doute réussi le coup de force
d'obtenir la libération de leur dernier
otage au Liban avant que Mohamed amadey
ne soit relâché fite réussie à l'ouest
pour C Allemands de l'Est en un seul
weekend un 6e a été arrêté par les
gardes frontières en essayant de
franchir le mur à
Berlin manifestation hier soir à Bagdad
en Irak devant l'ambassade américaine le
régime iraakien fait donner la foule
pour protester contre le Sénat américain
en revanche à Paris vous le voyez une
poignée de représentants de la
communauté kurde ont manifesté cet
après-midi contre les sévice dont leurs
compatriotes sans patrie sont victimes
depuis des semaines en Irak c'est un
assassineon esse au fil des siècles et
des régimes de rayer ASI de la carte
complexe de cette partie du monde
Jacques Merl et Daniel l reviennent de
la frontière turque où les réfugiés
arrivent par
milliersode d'un peuple dans la chaleur
et la
poussière l'image du premier con voit
des 100000 réfugiés
CD
la frontière est en haut de cette
montagne à quelques centaines de mètres
depuis mardi dernier elle est
complètement fermé par
l'arméeienne derrière cette montagne
40000 C sont aujourd'hui
C réussi à passerord d'une rivière
sovise campement dans le silence
cetteall parfois le bruit lointain de
canonade parouras C si reconnaissable
odeur de mort leur maison était là-bas à
Bergin barolan tous ces villages du
Kurdistan bombardés de manière
terrifiante depuis le 27
juillet les enfants emportent encore la
marque dans les yeux et sur la peau de
leur
visage le gouvernement turc d'abord
surpris par la soudaineté et
l'importance de cet exode a réagi avec
une grande efficacité tous les camions
de la région ont été réquisitionnés et
jour après jour se forment
d'interminables convois pour transporter
en des camps mieux aménagés ces milliers
de réfugiés les derniers kilomètres ne
sont pas les plus faciles sous un soleil
de plomb et sur des pistes de terre et
de caillou il faut encore attendre que
la route se libère dans les gorges
étroit de la vallée du Zab le moindre
incident retient des dizaines et des
dizaines de
camions ils sont 10000 aujourd'hui dans
ce convoi de réfugiés bloqués ici camion
est en panne et bloque la route depuis
plusieurs heures 10000 réfugiés ils ont
quitté leur village le 25 août à la
suite de de terrible bombardement
chimique il marchaient la nuit se
cachant le jour et ont franchit lesé
Coles à plus de 3000 m sur ces montagnes
très difficiles d'accès parmi tous ces
réfugiés on trouve aujourd'hui de
nombreux témoignages sur la gravité des
bombardements qui viennent d'avoir lieu
au
Kurdistan
avion sont arrivés un matin ils ont
lâché des bombes qui faisaient des
fumées rouges vert jaune et après tout
le monde était mort les vaches aussi
tous les animaux cé
Affre C terrible témoignage se multip
km la frtière irenne avant Mme d'inaller
les tes mis à le disposition il vienent
à nous avec une
grandeitéous qui BR les
yeuxard et que tout qui fais mourir tous
les êtres
vivantsille cheveux là où sa tête
touchait le sol pendant son sommeil
comme si la terre était encore imprégnée
de substances
chimique cet autre nous présente son
bébé à la peau couverte de cloque rouge
ce sont les seuls signes de
l'utilisation d'armes chimiques par les
iraquien utilisation que Bagdad continue
de nier pas de blessés grave ici seuls
les blessés légers purent franchir la
montagne mais tous ces réfugiés qui
arrivent de jour comme de nuit ne sont
pas encore sortis de toutes leurs
épreuves
ce camp est à 2000 m d'altitude dans 2
mois il fera moins 20 degrés la nuit il
y aura 2 m de neige et dans tous ces
camps qui sait exactement 10 20 ou 30000
enfants de moins de 10
ans précaution diplomatique ou non les
autorités d'Ankara affirment aujourd'hui
que leurs équipes sanitaires n'ont pas
constaté de blessures ou de brûlure
constaté par des armes chimiques le
gouvernement britannique dit au
contraire avoir des preuves vante
l'accusation donc continue de peser dans
laavallangeche des faits d'hivers de
plus en plus d'histoire de viol en
France comment un homme apparemment
rangé peut aussi pendant 15 ans se
prouver être un pervers impénitent c'est
la question que l'on se pose ce soir à
ex après les aveux d'Alain Garcia on le
verra dans un instant mais d'abord cette
proposition du conseil de discipline de
l'aéronautique civile 8 ans de
suspension pour le pilote de l'Airbus
d'erinter qui s'était écrasé en dernier
àch Emmanuel
vanagier à gauche Michel assouin le
commandant de bord de l'Airbus 8 ans de
suspension proposé à sa droite pierre
maziierre le copilote de à 3 mois de
suspension la décision finale appartient
au ministre des Transports jamais
jusqu'àalors il n'a pris de sanctions
plus sévères que celle recommandée par
le conseil de discipline la carrière de
Michel assouine ne serait pas pour
autant terminée cette suspension de
licence ne lui interdirait pas de
piloter des appareils de moins de 20
tonnes
18 morts 30 blessés graves hier à Kabul
Afghanistan très importants dégâts
matériels une quarantaine de magasins
détruit le plus grave attentat depuis
des années dans la capitale afghane les
explosifs étaient dissimulés dans une
voiture stationné dans la principale rue
de Cabou après l'explosion incendie de
cet immeuble de 5 étages prisonnière des
flammes plusieurs personnes n'ont pas
hésité à se jeter du haut de l'édifice
l'attentat n'a pas été
revendiqué pas de victime en Irlande du
Nord attente à manqué matin contre cette
vill près de Belfast la cible le chef de
l'administration britannique en Ulster
sir Kenneth Bloomfield il n'a pas été
blessé l'attentat a été revindiiqué par
l'IRA l'armée républicaine
irlandaise tout le monde en rêvera
personne ne l'aura Oxia ne sera pas à
vendre dans ce prototype de recherche
peugeot a mis tout son savoir-faire
équipement ultraoderne carrosserie en
fibre synthétique informatique à
bord sous le capot 6 cylindres en V
turbo compressé 680 chevaux Oxia trônera
sur le stand Peugeot du prochain salon
de l'OTO à Paris fin septembre à dévorer
des yeux
seulement 45 ans mariés deux enfants
honorablement connus depuis plus de 20
ans dans le village de la medde près de
l'étan de ber Alain Garcia a avoué
samedi dernier violer ça me plaît a-t-il
déclaré au policier qui le pense
responsable de la centaine de viols
recensés depuis 15 ans dans la région
Michel montponet et Marcel Martin des
dizaines de femmes violées avaient
témoigné le violeur d'ex ressemble à ce
buste robot réalisé par la police et
pourtant il va falloir 15 ans 15 ans
pour arrêter et confondre enfin Alain
Garcia quand il est interpellé on lui
reproche un viol mais à la surprise des
services de police horreur il va en
avouer plus d'une centaine l'homme qui
terrorisait les quartiers d'ex est tombé
dans cette seule résidence 70 femmes
seront ses victimes toujours une même
technique escaladait une fenêtre menacé
d'un couteau et passer à l'acte et
pourtant dans son village de la médé
chez lui Alain Garcia est décrit comme
un mari modèle un charmant garçon sans
histoire c'est un homme très bien
hein vraiment euh on est vraiment
bouleversé et surpris de de ce qui se
passe parce que on l'estimit beaucoup
tout le quartier on est sidéré on a cru
qu'il était tombé dans un tracanard
son fils traumatisé n'a pas souhaité
parler devant notre caméra il ne peut
croire que son père prétextant ses
footing quotidien part en fait faire de
nouvelles victimes insoupçonnable un mot
qui revient dans toutes les bouches même
à son lieu de travail avec ses collègues
au garage pas pass le temps Guer
Méch mais je n'ai jamais été violent
plaide maintenant Garcia depuis la
maison ex une façon terrible d'ignorer
que viol veut dire violence la vie d'un
médecin maintenant docteur flyer bonsoir
vous êtes docteur en psychologie expert
auprès du tribunal de reins et si l'on
peut dire expert en viol le cas du bon
monsieur Garcia est-ce que c'est un cas
tout à fait exceptionnel où est-ce qu'il
y a des seuils de comportement de la
normalité à la perversité à la maladie
oui bien sûr il y a des seuils de
comportement évidemment par contre
lorsqu'on a affaire à des criminels ver
tel que cet homme il faut pas être
étonné si vous voulez de son
comportement notamment de son
intégration sociale ou familial c'est
j'allais dire même cliniquement un des
paramètres que l'on reconnaît
relativement souvent dans ce type
d'attitude déviante alors 20 ans de pour
20 % en 1 an 20 % de viol en plus en
France 20 % de plainte ou de cas et
pourquoi oui deux explications une
explication à court terme à savoir que
le comportement des victimes de viol a a
changé grâce d'ailleurs aux médias il y
a une information beaucoup plus
importante maintenant qui est donnée par
conséquent on peut quantifier davantage
les plaintes une explication à plus long
terme si vous voulez il y a eu une une
permissivité sexuelle depuis plus de 15
ans maintenant dans notre société qui ne
s'est peut-être pas
accompagné d'une d'une prise de
conscience collective liée quand même au
tabou sexuel euh si vous voulez ça a
déclenché très très certainement dans le
tissu social une sorte d'affaiblissement
de la culpabilité et de la censure avec
par conséquent une augmentation du
passage à l'acte et une et une
banalisation du passage à l'acte docteur
bryer merci pour cet éclairage médical
sur cette difficile et douloureuse
affaire passons à l'étude d'un tout
autre type de comportement le
comportement d'un très grand sportif un
comportement passionnant à analyser au
fil des années mats Vilander est depuis
hier soir le numéro 1 du tennis mondial
il met un terme au long règne d'Ivan
Lendel comment devient-on numéro 1
l'analyse de Jean Mamer à défaut d'être
devenu le plus riche mats villander est
devenu hier soir le plus fort il est en
prime le premier suédois vainqueur de
l'US Open une couronne bien méritée CIN
victoires dans la saison dont Roland
Garos et l'Australie deux autres
tournois du grand schlem ajoutz à cela
la coupe desvis avec l'équipe de Suède
dont il fait partie et le palmarès est
comp
mais à quoi doit-il cette
impressionnante série de succès pas
seulement à sa grande concentration et
ce fameux TIC de raccorder sa raquette
après chaque point ou bien encore à ce
geste fétichiste mise au point depuis
peu ses succès il les doit au progrès
qu'il a effectué sur un cours à un
tennis plus offensif hier soir par
exemple il n'a pas hésité à monter au
filet pour conclure les
points encore mieux il est monté sur son
service pour bluffer Ian
Lendel tactique aussi avec ce revers à
une main inconnu jusqu'ici cette balle
glissée sans être décisive a poussé le
plus souvent Ivan Lendel à la
faute étrange vilandur même roi il ne
laisse percer qu'une indiciible joie il
est par nature timide et réservé il ne
s'extériorise vraiment que sur un cours
et cela lui vaudra demain d'être sacré
champion du
mondeons encore les pronostics de
Pierrette BR pour le tiercer demain mon
chant dans le prix de l'Orangerie vous
les lisez en même temps que moi le 15 le
8 le 7 le 17 le 14 le 6 le 3 et le 5
dans un instant Laurent Cabrol vous dira
la couleur du temps de demain et c'est
Philippe lefit qui vous présentera notre
dernière édition du journal vers 23h20
merci d'avoir suivi celui-ci je suis
heureuse de vous retrouver vous m'avez
manqué j'espère vous retrouver tous les
soirs à 20h à demain très bonne soirée